what
i'm dead ring a ding ding you got it
bucko
saint peter it's my name and a title
don't worry either out oh wow i can't
believe how the i'm in heaven i'm gonna
see nana again and drew and bailey take
it easy guy with a surprising amount of
dead friends you're not in yet these are
the outskirts of heaven you still have
to be let in the gates so
what are you doing you've never been to
like a fancy restaurant where the maitre
d is like we are all booked and then
he's like unless
you want a bribe i did not say that i
did not say that for all intents and
purposes i just have a cough
you can get sick in heaven no
no you can't
um
uh i died in my sleep so i don't really
have any money
okay
well let's let's figure this out let's
talk it out uh what what uh what uh
what else could you do
something you could do even if you don't
have anything on you
maybe to something i have on me
talking about a robe boner
i'm not gay oh don't worry that's an
earth thing
up here there's no such thing as gay or
straight or
bribes i i don't really know what to say
you don't really have to say anything
this is more of a do situation
but i don't think god would want me to
it's not about
what you should or shouldn't do up here
that's earth thinking this is an eternal
landscape where all consciousness has
come to merge into one eternal
conscience so there's no right or wrong
or light or dark it's all happening
everything is everything and it's
occurring at the same time
so lose the shirt
you want to meet john lennon right
he plays a concert every night mostly
new stuff then he plays imagine
gets real awkward when he gets the
imagine there's no heaven part it's a
big laugh
all right
now let's get this saint peter past your
pearly gates
it was to see if you get in and you do
you get in you passed
so the
test to get into heaven is to see if
i'll blow you it's uh it's a parable
yeah you have to look past the story to
see the true meaning of christmas
kid
i was [ __ ] with you this whole time
don't look so mad normally i let the guy
blow me first
keep that shirt off beautiful let god
enjoy what he made
you